more than 20 former students from the
antonio bravo institute in the western
province of mendoza
have already found the courage to speak
out it was their testimonies that helped
put two priests
nicola corradi and oracio corbacho in
prison in 2019
both for more than 40 years
now they'll again have to bring up those
painful memories as nine more accused
are put on trial
the charges against them including
sexual abuse and corruption of minors
through much of their lives they
couldn't communicate because they didn't
have sign language
the school prohibited it so they
couldn't describe what had happened to
them
then no one believed them not until a
sign language teacher reported it in
2016.
the accused this time include two nuns
four former directors of the institute
a psychologist and a cook all who deny
the charges against them
lawyers for the victims say they have
strong evidence and are confident
they'll get convictions
they tell you what no mother or father
wants to know
that your child has been abused for a
long time
the argentine pope francis has called
child abusers ravenous wolves who must
prepare for divine justice
but victims and those battling on their
behalf see their case is part of a wider
problem
in argentina and around the world that
the church authorities won't face what
they're accused of
the first thing that has to happen is
what the united nations said in 2014
a catholic church must stop systematic
cover-ups of the evidence
because as long as they're doing that
there will be more victims
[Applause]
but many questions about what went on
behind those gates still remain
what the nine are accused of what the
two priests have already been convicted
of
represents for many a crime even more
heinous because the children were deaf
because they were perceived to be more
vulnerable
therefore the exploitation of trust by
those responsible for looking after them
seems to be even greater
much of the trial will be conducted
virtually as the kovid 19 pandemic
continues to devastate argentina
and with nearly 200 witnesses scheduled
to testify many of them requiring sign
language interpreters
it could take up to a year a year
exposing deep wounds that some must face
and others would rather avoid
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires